- Right.
- So you also did something
else that's very cool.
So, you recently, you
opened the Prada show?
- Yes, that's what you do.
- So I mean, what!
(audience clapping)
So, how did that happen?
- How did that come about?
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] That's so cool.
Look at you!
- [Amanda] Damn, damn, damn.
- [Kyle] I know.
- [Kelly] Look at that blue steel look.
Oh my gosh.
Look at him look at the camera. Aye!
- There it is.
- Was that so fun?
- One thing is going through my head.
- [Kelly] What?
- Don't fall down.
- [Kelly] Amen.
- Do not trip.
(Kelly laughs)
That was really my motivation.
Raf Simons, who's working with
Mrs. Prada, Miuccia Prada.
He's been there for two years now
and he's always kind of
in my stuff, Twin Peaks
and the David Lynch stuff.
- Yeah.
- And he invited myself and
a number of other actors,
including Jeff Goldblum.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Who's also in the show.
- [Kelly] Oh, I've worked
with him, he's fun.
- He's lovely.
- Or, been on the show.
- And so they said, come
to Milan and do this
and I said, is it really gonna happen
because of COVID and
everything, and it did happen.
And they took such good care of us.
They were so gracious, so kind.
- It's such a cool idea.
- It's so fun.
- Yeah.
- I mean, it just like just go
and have a good time in Milan.
- Yeah.
- You know.
- Fine.
- Yeah.
After that, then you go out
and you eat pasta afterwards.
You don't eat pasta before,
you have to go out afterwards.
- Why I could never be a model.
(all laugh)
One of the many reasons.
So wait, so that, that Prada
video was on your TikTok.
So how does your teenage son,
how does your 13 year-old feel about that?
- Oh, he always cringes, he cringes.
- Oh, he did?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Didn't think at all, like that's rad.
- No, anything I do on TikTok,
he's like, "Dad that's just not cool."
(Kelly groans)
You know, I'm still old school,
so I like TikTok to be little nice
and kind of planned out, you know?
- [Kelly] Okay.
- And I think the thing to
do is you just kind of do-
- [Kelly] It's supposed
to be kind of like-
- Spontaneous, right.
- But they say it's spontaneous,
its not spontaneous.
- [Kyle] Not really, yeah.
- You know how many times they did that,
before they posted it, yeah.
- [Kyle] Yeah, yeah.
- They be lyin'.
Yeah, all those people,
they're like, "Oh no, wait
this angle is better."
- [Kyle] Okay, I feel
better, I feel better.
(all laugh)
Thanks, Kelly.
- [Kelly] It's not you, you're
not cringey, you're awesome.